to redeem my skill here my woke  commercial discerning skill give me the  bonus one  you know pride is about joy nickelodeon  connection but most importantly this  year and every year pride is about  visibility it's nick it's nickelodeon i  bet hey brent hey lady  guess what today with the help of the  family of brands we are going to  transform you into your most fabulous  self  pride is the time of year where we get  to celebrate who we are  whatever you do  know that this pride is for you i like  your birthday did you celebrate that on  your birthday you are worthy and you  belong  on pride you get to celebrate who you  are as long as it's like a very specific  weird sexual  yes who you are a victorian woman june  4th as proctor and gamble teams up with  i heart radio for can't cancel pride  die hard radio and procter and gamble is  always fracturing campbell it's like the  wokest thing